what's up buddy you know latest La
lifestyle you live here now no I've been
out here for the month though oh okay I
feel like I'm just you know it's like
second home now I've been coming out
here since a kid you feel me I'm always
in L.A every couple months you feel me
well now you're like officially 18 right
finally yeah it's kind of crazy because
like I feel like when the overwhelming
song what were you 12 like 11 yeah crazy
yeah like 11 12 yeah 12 yeah I probably
like 10 and 12. where are you originally
from Philadelphia Philly yeah born and
raised that's crazy so you pop off at 12
years old and kind of like Peak
SoundCloud era of Music
um
yeah I feel like we kind of have seen
you kind of grow up in front of our eyes
yeah man uh for you like how does it
feel to kind of finally make it to being
an adult
it's crazy I mean
it's just and I felt like an adult for
the longest time because I've been doing
so much growing stuff like just going
out to clubs and like stuff like that
like strip clubs and like since I was
like 16 you're gonna right [__] like
that like it's just like ever since a
kid I've been living this growing
lifestyle are you feeling right it just
now it's just like I kind of been doing
all that stuff so I'm kind of just
trying to focus on the business now you
feel me just mature with it you feel me
I'm having fun nobody do you feel like
like growing up in a rap game you kind
of lost a lot of like of your innocence
you know what I'm saying in terms yeah
but I mean
everything that I go through is destined
for like right I knew that I wanted to
be a rapper ever since a little kid and
it's like the [__] I was doing I was
drawing myself out on a piece of paper
performing in front of crowds when I was
like 10 and then a couple years later it
happened came true right 20 000 People
In This Crowd you know what I'm saying
like Mad Decent show with Diplo you know
what I'm saying like and it's just a
year after I wrote that on a piece of
paper it's like
that's crazy it's crazy coming from
Philly because your music is obviously
like more like melodic more like you
know you know when I when I hear your
[__] I don't really hear a lot of Philly
influence if you will yeah what is it
safe to say you really as a kid the
whole like Philly Meek Mill freeway [__]
kind of like missed you yeah um
I never like I listened to that type of
stuff but I never like
was
like trying to do stuff that everybody
else was doing like I was literally
making this for my soul like I knew I
went to make music you gotta understand
like I was working with all the
big producers that was that that's
popping right now like right for sure
like filthy working on dying like the
people that just did cardio tape uh yeah
he produced a lot for the Poland song
for Yadi like those are the guys you
were working with yeah like 11 you know
what I'm saying so like we was creating
a whole new sound in the city with the
trash [__] and like just like
people know like if you ask around they
gonna know you know what I'm saying so
like
day where when I was a kid I was just
posting a bunch of like Twitter Snippets
I would freestyling on Twitter and they
found me on Twitter and they would just
send me a bunch of beats
and then from there we just start going
crazy and like just making a whole new
sound and then that's what made it it
stick out I feel like right and then a
lot of my early stuff was actually
trenched out like it was real like
Rhett I mean like not a lot of people
here but like the real ones know like
Michael Myers low-key those were way
before overwhelming right overwhelming
wasn't my first song overwhelming was
just
um something that we planned out so it
could go up you get what I'm saying with
the fidget Spinners with the Kids on the
Block fidget spinner gang man I think of
that I think five years ago I think of
fidget Spinners and I think of you yeah
oh God that's what everybody say it was
like we capitalized on it without even
trying you know what I'm saying what
happened to fidget Spinners them shits
are just out yeah I don't know I ain't
seeing a fidget spinner in a minute
those things were [__] lit for a
while it was right
um so give me like for you man because I
do feel like anytime
you know you go through such a a real
fast path to fame viralness Etc
especially at a young age it's probably
a lot of uh stuff that's hard to deal
with you know stuff that you're probably
looking back on is there anything that
you feel like you took from that era
that you learned from or any mistakes
you feel like you might have made yeah I
haven't been through deals on deals and
[__] and like how many deals have you
been assigned to two Okay like two major
deals okay I mean two major labels I was
trying to Warner Brothers at first and
then Motown with capital and you're a
free agent now now free agent
independent fully 100 I just I had two
because I ain't never took that route
and I wanted to since the beginning of
my career it was just a lot of stuff
that was like I had it was just a lot of
stuff like you know when in the
beginning of your career it's like
everybody coming to you with deals oh
you got to do this oh you got it right
you feel me so then but I luckily I got
out of both of them and now I'm able to
do what I want drop when I went right
when you feel me and it's like one thing
I learned from that like every sign
artists want to be independent area
independent artist it's like you gotta
take what you got and really take
advantage of it for sure whatever
situation it is 100 uh how involved like
how involved has your mom been in your
career oh like she's my manager right
now so so your mom is like steering the
ship yeah I mean in the beginning she
was scared like I had it for I had not
first but like I had to kind of like
help like be like it's cool you're gonna
be good like you could do this you know
what I'm saying like because she was
scared to be a manager like she ain't
know nothing about the business we ain't
know nothing about the business we were
coming in you know what I'm saying right
we coming into this like really
trying to figure it out it's got to be
kind of hard because like the motherland
stinks kick in but you're also a popping
rapper so that you're around a bunch of
[__] there's hella but my mom had me at
15 so in the beginning it was like she
was kind of scared but then
she got so your mom had you when she was
15. okay it's like brother sister
relationship almost like we just we
close like that you're feeling like how
old is your mom now she's 32. damn I'm
older than your mom [__] that's
crazy shout out to moms okay yeah your
mama it's probably your birthday on the
16th happy birthday tomorrow damn so
your mom and you were just kind of
figuring this [__] out as a as it was
pretty much together I'm still in school
and then pretty much all that stuff
happens years later I didn't even get to
go to high school I had to drop out
before I even went to high school so you
never even got to make it to ninth grade
I went home school okay and it was to
the point where it was like the home
school wasn't really doing nothing right
so I I was ended up just like Reese like
just copying and pasting everything it
was just like cheating it pretty much it
was like it was just too easy you know
what I'm saying like so like I just
realized like bro you could do your own
research you know what I'm saying we
have computers and phones now which is
like AI is killing our brain slowly but
at the same time
is learning you can learn from it
because it's creating a bigger iCloud
brain you know what I'm saying so
I feel like that's what's happening
right now so uh did you get a GED or
anything or did you just kind of no I do
not I ain't get no GED I dropped out
dropped out so when was the last time
eighth grade we were in school pretty
much yeah I I don't even remember the
grade it was on it was on the computer
so it was all online yeah you can't even
hear that's crazy it's like
at first because at first I had to go
home school because everybody knew me
because you were so popular at school
but then everybody had to go home school
because of Corona Kobe yeah yeah damn
well there it is man I'll say Grand wait
yeah covet Corona same [__]
um so fast forward to now obviously
you're 18 now you got new music coming
um do you feel like
being independent is more like um
does it fit fit you more because you can
kind of drop when you want yeah I feel
like and now that I'm 18 I can finally
be myself you feel me like before it
felt like I had to keep certain [__]
like secret or just stay low-key cause
like
it's like I don't want to get caught up
and it means to like with like my mom I
want my mom getting caught up with
nothing because I'm a minor you know
what I'm saying meaning like what like
because you were we go out do what I
need to do do what I want to do you know
what I'm saying just be out partying
whatever I want to do were you doing
like a ton of drugs no I wasn't doing no
choice well that's good like everybody
around me was but it's like you gotta
keep a strong mind like so you never
participated in any other [__] I
don't know it's like you gotta know when
to draw the line like everybody around
me be doing crazy [__] like I'd have
been in parties where everybody sniffing
[__] like in the first show I had people
off Academy my mom there you go what I'm
saying was your mama Academy
I don't know why I don't do none of that
[__] well that's good at least she
passed that down to you yeah because
that would have been super easy for you
to like not because bro I've seen it
from the jump like people tweaked out in
my shoulders
tweaked out I never wanted to do like I
never right gonna sniff nothing in my
life you feel me maybe if I'm in
Columbia with a badass you mean but like
other than that I ain't doing that [__]
you feel me gotta be right you know what
I'm saying you haven't been to Columbia
yet obviously no one day well you're 18
now you can go where you want man you
got your passport yet yeah I got my
passport yeah they had my passport I had
to go to uh London in Paris when I was
like 13. so crazy walk like a fashion
show with NFL I saw that yeah